I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. And welcome to a very special bonus episode of Office Ladies. Yeah. Today we are talking about what motivates you. And what motivates us. All right, so this bonus episode of Office Ladies is brought to you by the folks at Buick, makers of the all-new EnVision, and they've asked us to share how we make our Office Ladies podcast each week. Yeah.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。欢迎收听《办公室女郎》的一个非常特殊的特别番外节目。是的。今天我们来聊聊是什么激励了你。以及是什么激励了我们。好的，所以本期《办公室女郎》特别番外节目由别克的各位赞助播出，他们打造了全新昂科威，他们邀请我们分享我们每周是如何制作《办公室女郎》播客的。是的。
A lot goes into making this show. Yeah. It's very rewarding. It is. Today we are going to break it down for you and talk all about what keeps us motivated and moving. And then we're also going to talk a little bit about BFFs. Yeah. Let's do it. Angela, you know, I love my structure. Honey, do I know it? So I have fast facts for this bonus episode. You do? What are your fast facts? All right, fast fact number one. This one is from the folks at Buick. There you go. I mean, when you sponsor an episode, you get to ask the first question. I like it. By the way, you guys, we zoomed with the Buick folks and they are the nicest bunch of people and they're really into the podcast, which I don't know.
制作这个节目需要付出很多努力。是的。非常有意义。确实如此。今天我们将为你详细拆解，聊聊是什么让我们保持动力不断前进。然后我们还会聊聊关于闺蜜的话题。是的。我们开始吧。安吉拉，你知道的，我喜欢有条理。亲爱的，我能不知道吗？所以我为这个特别番外节目准备了快讯。是吗？你的快讯是什么？好的，快讯第一条。这一条来自别克的朋友们。就是这样。我是说，当你赞助一集节目时，你就可以问第一个问题。我喜欢。顺便说一句，伙计们，我们和别克的朋友们进行了视频通话，他们人真的超级好，而且他们对这个播客非常感兴趣，我不知道。
That just made me feel so good. I feel good, too. They had clearly listened to every episode. Yeah. All right. Anyway, here it is. Jenna and Angela, you are both incredible multi-hyphenates. So we imagine a lot goes into keeping everything moving. When you told me they call this multi-hyphenates, you know I had to look it up. Yeah. Okay. So according to the Cambridge Dictionary, a multi-hyphenate is someone who does several different jobs, especially in the entertainment industry. For example, we are actor, writer, podcasters. Yeah. I would add producers. Yeah. And we run our own business. Yeah. What else? We scrapbook. Is that in the entertainment industry? We love a good sale. That's probably shopping. I don't know. I would count it as part of
这让我感觉太美妙了。我也感觉很好。他们显然听了每一集。是的。好吧。不管怎样，内容是这样的。珍娜和安吉拉，你们都是身兼多职的奇才。所以我们想象要维持这一切运转一定付出了很多努力。当你告诉我他们称这为“身兼多职”时，你知道我不得不去查一下。是的。好吧。根据剑桥词典的解释，身兼多职的人是指从事几种不同工作的人，特别是在娱乐行业。例如，我们是演员、作家、播客主持人。是的。我会加上制片人。是的。而且我们经营自己的生意。是的。还有什么？我们做手艺拼贴。这在娱乐行业里吗？我们喜欢大促销。那可能是购物。我不知道。我会把它算作我们
our multi-hyphenates. Well, Angela, Buick is bringing everyone a challenge to make the best of their Mondays. So they want to know, do we have any rituals that kick off our week? And are you more of a Monday motivation person or a Friday feeling person? I mean, I'm not really sure what they mean by Monday motivation. Is that like someone who's like, let's go and tackle the week. We're going to hit the ground running on Monday because that is definitely not me. That is not you. I am not that. I am more of a Friday feeling person. Yeah. Everyone who listens to Office Ladies probably knew that. I don't know. Is that shade? Are you throwing shade at me? I'm not throwing you shade. No, not at all. I'm sure it's
身兼多职的一部分。好吧，安吉拉，别克给大家带来了一个挑战，让大家充分利用周一。所以他们想知道，我们有没有什么仪式感来开启一周的工作？你是更倾向于“周一动力”型还是“周五感觉”型？我是说，我其实不太确定他们所说的“周一动力”是什么意思。这就像是那种说“让我们去大干一场吧”的人吗？我们周一就要全力以赴，因为那绝对不是我。那不是你。我不是那样的人。我更倾向于“周五感觉”型。是的。每个听《办公室女郎》的人大概都知道这一点。我不知道。这是在暗讽吗？你在内涵我吗？我可没有暗讽你。不，完全没有。我确信这是
no surprise that I'm a Monday motivation person. This is why we're such a great team. It really is. And I definitely have rituals that kick off my week. We work mostly from home and a lot of what I struggle with is ignoring house chores when I'm supposed to be working. So I actually like to do things on Sunday evening to set myself up for success on Monday. So my Monday motivation starts on Sunday. Of course it does. Your Monday motivation starts on the weekend. That's so perfect. Here are some examples. I always make sure that we've done all the dishes so that I wake up to a clean sink. I have to wake up to a clean sink. This makes me very happy. Okay. We do all of our grocery shopping and meal planning over
毫无疑问，我是一个“周一动力”型的人。这就是为什么我们能成为如此棒的团队。确实如此。我确实有开启一周工作的仪式感。我们主要在家办公，我经常纠缠于在应该工作的时候去忽视家务活。所以我其实喜欢在周日晚上把事情做好，为周一的成功打好基础。所以我的周一动力从周日就开始了。理所当然。你的周一动力从周末就开始了。这太完美了。这里有一些例子。我总是确保我们把所有的碗筷都洗干净，这样我醒来时就能看到一个干净的水槽。我必须在一个干净的水槽醒来。这让我非常开心。好的。我们所有的杂货采购和膳食计划都是在
the weekend. And I like to have a clean home office on Monday morning. Like I'll even write down a list of priorities for my week in a notepad and I'll put it on my desk next to my computer on Sunday night. This is how I set myself up for a great Monday. I mean, I know this about you. And I also know if one of those things doesn't happen, things can get walkie. Oh, I lose it. I lose it. Well, I'm definitely more of a Friday feeling person. I feel like I need something to work towards, you know, like that light at the end of the tunnel kind of thing. Yeah. To get me motivated. And I have found with myself, if I think about like the big picture, like everything I have to do that day or everything
周末完成的。而且我喜欢在周一早上拥有一个干净的家庭办公室。甚至我会在周日晚上在记事本上写下我这周的优先级清单，然后把它放在我电脑旁边的桌子上。这就是我如何为美好的周一做好准备的。我是说，我很了解你。我也知道如果这些事情中有一件没做到，事情就会变得一团糟。哦，我会崩溃的。我会崩溃的。好吧，我绝对更倾向于“周五感觉”型。我觉得我需要有些盼头来为之奋斗，你知道的，就像隧道尽头的那道光一样。是的。来给我动力。我发现对我自己而言，如果我去想宏大的画面，比如我那天必须做完的所有事情或者所有
I have to do that week, I get overwhelmed. So I really just have to take it one day at a time. I set little like daily goals for myself and then I get a little reward. Oh, like what? I mean, it doesn't have to be anything big. Like I'll work a long day and say, you know what? I'm going to go for a nice walk and I'm going to look at flowers and I'm going to just let my mind wander. I mean, I'm not exercising. You understand this. Like this isn't like I'm nobody thought you were exercising. Don't worry. I'm not going to burn into calories, but that walk is like my mental break. I'm kind of the opposite of you, Angela. I have to take my walk first thing in the morning. I find that I can quiet
我这周必须做的事情，我就会感到不知所措。所以我真的只能一天过一天。我给自己设定一些小小的日常目标，然后我会得到一点小小的奖励。哦，比如什么？我是说，不需要是什么大事。比如我会努力工作一整天，然后说，你知道吗？我要去散个步，去看看花，让我的思绪自由驰骋。我是说，我可不是在锻炼。你懂的。这可不是……没人觉得你在锻炼。别担心。我才不会去燃烧卡路里呢，但那次散步就像是我的精神休憩。我和你有点相反，安吉拉。我必须在清晨第一件事就是去散步。我发现如果我活动身体，就能让
my brain if I work my body. But what I do each morning to set myself up for a great day at work, it also depends on what kind of work we're doing. For example, if we're working on our book, I have this little routine that I call my mental warmups. And I developed this from like, I mean, listen, lady, I listened to all these podcasts of like people who have suggestions on how to like organize your life. You know, I love them. You love that. You love like how to be successful five steps for every successful person. You love all that stuff. Oh yeah. So here's what I came up with. I do 15 minutes of reading and then 15 minutes of journaling. I set a timer, but during that time, I keep a notepad
大脑平静下来。但我每天早上为了一天的工作做好准备所做的事情，也取决于我们正在做什么样的工作。例如，如果我们正在写书，我有一个小常规，我称之为我的“精神热身”。我从……我是说，听着，女士，我听了所有这些播客，上面有人建议如何组织你的生活。你知道的，我喜欢这些。你喜欢那个。你喜欢比如“每个成功人士的五个成功步骤”。你喜欢所有这些东西。哦，是的。所以这是我想出来的。我进行15分钟的阅读，然后进行15分钟的日记。我设定了一个计时器，但在那期间，我会在身边放一个记事本，
next to me and I write down anything that jumps in my mind. Like it might be an idea for writing later, but it might be a chore or an email that I need to return. So I jot it down and then I let it kind of flow through me and I keep reading and I keep journaling. And then when I'm done, I look at my list and I prioritize it. I say what really needs to be done from this list before I start writing and what can wait and somehow getting it down on the paper. It's this way where I've tricked my brain into knowing that it'll get done, but I can let it go for now. And it doesn't have to sit in my brain. It doesn't have to keep reminding me to do it because it's on the paper now. Right, right. So that will
把任何突然闪过脑海的东西写下来。比如这可能是以后写作的一个灵感，但也可能是一项家务活或一封我需要回复的邮件。所以我把它记下来，然后让它顺其自然地流过我的内心，我继续阅读，继续写日记。当我完成后，我会看着我的清单并按轻重缓急排序。我说在这个清单上，在开始写作之前什么事是真正必须完成的，什么事可以先放一放，不知怎么的，把它写在纸上。通过这种方式，我欺骗了自己的大脑，让它知道事情会完成的，但我现在可以放手了。它不必一直留在我脑子里。它不必一直提醒我去完成，因为它现在已经在纸上了。对，对。所以这会
really set me up for a great day of intense writing. I like that. I think that's just you practicing self-care because I know we've been friends a long time that sometimes if you get a thought in your head, you've got to do something with it. You can't just let it spin around up there. Containment is hard for me. Well, I think you're doing a great job. You know, Jenna, because I've sent you countless photos of me with my coffee mug on my back porch. I start my day by sitting on my porch. It's really simple. I mean, gosh, sometimes I only get to sit for five minutes, maybe 10 minutes, but it just feeds my soul. And I don't know if it's like a Southern thing.
真正让我为紧张的写作日做好准备。我喜欢这样。我觉得这只是你在进行自我关爱，因为我知道我们做朋友很久了，有时候如果你脑子里冒出一个想法，你就必须采取行动。你不能让它一直在上面旋转。克制对我来说很难。好吧，我觉得你做得非常棒。你知道的，珍娜，因为我给你发过无数张我拿着咖啡杯坐在后廊的照片。我的一天是从坐在门廊上开始的。真的很简单。我是说，天哪，有时候我只能坐五分钟，也许十分钟，但它就是能滋养我的灵魂。我不知道这算不算南方人的习俗。
Every one of my family at some point in the day sits on their porch. And my dad used to say, find yourself a thinking spot and take a moment. And it just makes me feel good. So I guess my thinking spot is my back porch. And I like to just have my cup of tea. I'm a big tea drinker, you know, and I sort of listen to the birds chatter. And it's like my moment of calm before kids and school and life and work and all of that just kicks into high gear. And I live for those few moments in the morning and on days that I don't get it because, you know, you don't always get to have that little self-care moment. Oh, yeah. I don't quite feel like myself, you know.
我家的每个人在一天中的某个时刻都会坐在门廊上。我爸爸过去常常说，给自己找个思考的地方，静静待上一会儿。这让我感觉很好。所以我想我的思考地方就是我的后廊。我喜欢只喝一杯茶。你知道的，我是个茶饮爱好者，我有点像是在听小鸟叽喳。这就像是我在孩子、学校、生活、工作以及所有这些事情进入白热化之前的那段平静时刻。我为早上的那几分钟而活着，而在那些没有得到的日子里——因为你知道，你不可能总能拥有那小段自我关爱时刻——哦，是的。我感觉有点不像我自己了，你知道的。
So it's a really small act of self-care that took me years to figure out how much it means to me. And it's just really a gift that I love to be able to make for myself in the morning. But guess what day is my favorite day of the week? Friday feeling. Friday, because I try to give myself a double reset. So I have my morning porch time, right, with my cup of tea. And then on Fridays, after I've worked my full day, I love to catch a little bit of the sunset, sit on the back porch with a glass of wine. And that I look forward to all week. That's my Friday feeling moment.
所以这是一件非常微小的自我关爱行为，我花了多年时间才弄明白它对我的意义有多重大。这真的就像是一份礼物，我很高兴每天早上能为自己创造这份礼物。但你猜我最喜欢星期几？“周五感觉”。星期五，因为我试着给自己来一次双重重置。所以我有了早上的门廊时光，对吧，手里拿着一杯茶。然后在星期五，在我工作了一整天之后，我喜欢去捕捉一点日落，端着一杯红酒坐在后廊上。我一整周都在期待那个时刻。那我的“周五感觉”时刻。
Lady, this is really making me want to be you, because that just all sounds lovely. Well, I was actually thinking, you know what, while I'm sitting out there having my cup of tea, listening to the birds, maybe if I took a little notepad with me, I could jot down some of the things I wanted to do that day. And then I would have my list and not forget anything. Yeah. Do you see how great this is when you share your rituals? Yeah. I like it.
女士，这真的让我很想变成你，因为这一切听起来都太美妙了。好吧，我其实在想，你知道吗，当我在外面喝茶、听小鸟叫的时候，也许如果我随身带个小本子，我就可以把那天想做的一些事情记下来。然后我就会有清单，不会忘事了。是的。你看，分享你的仪式感是多么棒的一件事啊！是的。我喜欢。
Well, thank you, Buick, for kicking things off. Later in the episode, we're going to tell you what we think of the Buick envisions. Spoiler alert. Yeah. We love them. We love them. All right. Should I move on to Fast Fact Number Two? Yeah. Fast Fact Number Two, we wouldn't be making an Office Ladies podcast if we had not been
好吧，谢谢别克为我们开启了这一切。在节目的后面，我们将告诉你我们对别克昂科威的看法。剧透预警。是的。我们爱死它们了。我们超爱它们。好了。我是说我应该进入快讯第二条吗？是的。快讯第二条，如果我们当初没有加入《办公室》，我们就不会制作《办公室女郎》这个播客。
on the office. Probably not. We wouldn't know each other. That is true. Well, we would have met. I didn't even think about that. That's so sad. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question from Michael S, who asked, when you guys have guests on
大概不会。我们不会认识彼此。这倒也是。好吧，我们本来会相遇的。我甚至没想过这一点。太遗憾了。是的。好吧，我们收到了来自迈克尔·S的一个粉丝提问，他问，当你们邀请嘉宾来
the podcast, you always ask them how they got to be on the office. But how did you two do it? Are you kidding me? Have we not talked about this? So I went back and we shared a little bit about it in the pilot episode of Office Ladies. Okay. But we haven't, like, talked about it. I feel like there's more to say. Okay.
播客时，你们总是问他们是如何加入《办公室》的。但你们两个是怎么做到的？你在开玩笑吗？我们之前没聊过这个吗？所以我回去看了一下，我们在《办公室》的首播集里分享过一点点。好吧。但我们并没有深入聊过。我觉得还有更多内容要说。好吧。
So in the pilot, you shared that you had originally auditioned for the role of Pam. Oh, yeah. And you didn't get the role, but you did not tell us about auditioning for Angela. Oh, my gosh. For Angela Martin? I'll tell you about it. Yes. Okay. So I auditioned for the role of Pam. They said I was too feisty. Bye-bye. But they said they liked me, but, you know, you hear that, you hear that, but you're like, okay, but does that mean I'll ever get called back? I just, I had to keep on moving. Yeah. You kept going.
所以在首播集里，你分享过你最初是为潘的角色试镜的。哦，是的。你没拿到那个角色，但你没有告诉我们你为安吉拉试镜的事。哦，天哪。为安吉拉·马丁试镜？我来告诉你。是的。好的。所以我是为潘的角色试镜的。他们说我太争强好胜了。拜拜。但他们说他们喜欢我，不过，你知道的，你听到这种话，你听到这些，但你会想：好吧，但这是否意味着我还会接到复试电话？我只是……我必须继续前进。是的。你坚持下去了。
I kept going. That's what you do. You just go to the next audition. That's right. You know, they say in Hollywood that the overnight success, you know, you've heard that expression, right? Yeah. Oh, she's an overnight success. I don't know who came up with that because my overnight success was nine years. Yeah.
我坚持下去了。这就是你所做的。你只要去参加下一场试镜就行了。没错。你知道的，好莱坞流传着一种说法，关于一夜成名，你知道这个词，对吧？是的。哦，她是一夜成名。我不知道是谁想出这个词的，因为我的一夜成名花了九年。是的。
Right? Yeah. You know those overnight success stories, because then when you're not an overnight success after like three months of being here, you feel like a failure, but actually, that's just normal. That is normal. For you, it was like, what? I got cast on the office after eight years. Eight years. Okay. So Jenna's overnight success was eight years. Mine was nine years, if that
对吧？是的。你知道那些一夜成名的故事，因为当你在来到这里大约三个月后还没有一夜成名时，你会觉得自己是个失败者，但实际上，这很正常。这很正常。对你来说，那是多久？我在八年后被选入《办公室》。八年。好吧。所以珍娜的一夜成名是八年。我的是九年，如果这
gives you an idea how long we were plugging away out here. And I had been doing every kind of odd job I could do. So I could audition, right? Yeah. I was a temp. I babysat. I was an operator at 1-800-DENNEST. I worked at restaurants, but here's the deal. I was also working at an improv sketch theater called Iowa West in Hollywood. I would work there, Jenna, so that I would get free classes. Oh, I did that so much of that. So much, right? You did this like work exchange. And here's what I was doing. And this cracks
能让你对我们在这里默默奋斗了多久有个概念的话。我一直在做我能做的各种零工。这样我才能去试镜，对吧？是的。我做过临时工。我当过保姆。我是1-800-DENNEST的接线员。我在餐馆工作过，但情况是这样的。我还曾在好莱坞一家名为“爱荷华西区”的即兴小品剧院工作。我在那里工作，珍娜，这样我就可以获得免费课程。哦，我做过好多这种。真的做了好多，对吧？你做了这种工作置换。而我当时在做的是这个。这让我
me up. I was helping the accountant. What? Yes. I was basically like the office manager, and I would balance the spreadsheet. I learned how to do profit and loss statements. I became really good with QuickBooks accounting software. Jenna, I had no idea I was training to be a fake accountant all along. That is amazing. Yeah. And so here I am, sitting in this little office of a theater, and I get a phone call
觉得很好笑。我在帮会计。什么？是的。我基本上就像是办公室经理，我还要平衡电子表格。我学会了如何做损益表。我变得非常擅长QuickBooks会计软件。珍娜，我当时根本不知道我一路走来其实是在为扮演一个假会计做培训。太神奇了。是的。所以我就坐在这里，坐在剧院的一个小办公室里，我接到了
from Allison Jones. They want me to come in and read for the stuffy accountant that sits in the corner. And I thought, come on, I got this, right? And there you go. Feisty Angela Martin was born. I got to read with Ken Qopis, and he told me I made a meal out of my scene. I'll never forget that expression. I walked out of their own Cloud 9. That is so cool. How many lines did you have in your audition? Did they write a scene for you? Yeah, they wrote a scene that didn't exist in the pilot. And it was like a couple of lines. It was so fun. And I mean, I thought, I think that went better than Pam.
艾莉森·琼斯的电话。他们想让我去读一下那个坐在角落里的古板会计的角色。我想，来吧，我能行，对吧？就这样。争强好胜的安吉拉·马丁诞生了。我和肯·库皮斯一起对台词，他告诉我我对我的场景进行了“加戏演绎”。我永远不会忘记那个词。我走出他们的办公室时简直像踩在云端。太酷了。你试镜时有多少台词？他们为你写了一个场景吗？是的，他们写了一个在首播集中并不存在的场景。大概有几句台词。非常有趣。而且我的意思是，我觉得那比潘的试镜要好。
Well, I had shared that when I auditioned, my reader was Phyllis Smith. Yes. Phyllis from the office. Right. Right. She read with us all, at least in that first round. Yes. Because she was the casting associate at Allison Jones' office. She was not an actress. Yeah. That's true. And we had shared that the way Phyllis got her job on the office was they were so impressed with how she read with all of us that they gave her a role.
好吧，我曾分享过，当我试镜时，和我对台词的是菲利斯·史密斯。是的。办公室里的菲利斯。没错。没错。她和我们所有人都对过台词，至少在第一轮是这样。是的。因为她是艾莉森·琼斯办公室的选角助理。她不是演员。是的。没错。我们曾分享过，菲利斯在《办公室》中获得工作的方式是，她和我们所有人对台词的表现给他们留下了深刻的印象，于是他们给了她一个角色。
Yeah. But what I didn't share is that I had been auditioning for various shows and roles that Allison Jones had been casting. And I had been reading with Phyllis for over five years before getting my audition for the office. Stop it. Yeah. Phyllis had been in your life for five years. Yeah. As like a casting associate.
是的。但我没有分享的是，我一直在为艾莉森·琼斯正在选角的各种剧集和角色试镜。在得到《办公室》的试镜之前，我和菲利斯一起对台词已经超过五年了。别开玩笑了。是的。菲利斯已经在你的生命中五年了。是的。作为选角助理。
Oh my gosh. And this is the part of the story that I thought fit in really well with our theme of staying motivated because like we were saying, I had been in Los Angeles, you know, knocking around for those eight years of my overnight success. And over those eight years, I watched a lot of people throw in the towel and be kind of like, forget it. I'm not doing this anymore. Same. It was like flies dropping, right? Yeah. You would have friends in acting class that would just pack it up and go home.
哦，天哪。这就是我觉得故事中非常契合我们保持动力这个主题的部分，因为就像我们一直说的，我在洛杉矶混了八年，也就是我一夜成名的那八年。在这八年里，我看着许多人放弃了，心里差不多就是算了，我再也不干这行了。我也是。就像苍蝇一样纷纷落地，对吧？是的。你在表演课上会有朋友直接收拾行李回老家了。
Exactly. And every time that happened, I thought, am I a crazy person for sticking this out? Right. Why am I still here? But every year some little thing would happen that would give me hope. Like year five, I got my first speaking role on a TV show. Which one? It was Spin City, the Charlie Sheen years. It was cast by Alison Jones and I read with Phyllis. It was just three lines as an actress. And when I got the role, I thanked Alison.
没错。每当那种事情发生，我就会想，我坚持下来是不是脑子有毛病？对啊。我为什么还留在这里？但每年总会有一些小事发生，给我带来希望。比如第五年，我在一部电视剧里得到了我的第一个有台词的角色。哪一部？是《政界小人物》，查理·辛在那几年的那部。由艾莉森·琼斯选角，我和菲利斯一起试读。作为女演员只有三台词。当我得到这个角色时，我感谢了艾莉森。
I told her, oh my gosh, I was really starting to lose hope. I was so happy to get this break. My family back home is finally going to see me on TV after five years. And you know what she said to me? What? She said the person you should thank is Phyllis. She put your audition at the top of the pile for the producers and she flagged you as our top choice. So Phyllis is one of the reasons that I had hope to stick around in Los Angeles long enough to audition with her three years later for the office.
我告诉她，哦，天哪，我真的开始失去希望了。我太高兴能得到这个突破了。远在家乡的家人终于可以在五年后在电视上看到我了。你知道她对我说什么吗？说什么？她说你应该感谢的人是菲利斯。她把你的试镜放在了制片人面前那一堆的最上面，并把你标记为我们的首选。所以菲利斯是我有希望在洛杉矶坚持呆下去的原因之一，以至于三年后能和她一起为《办公室》试镜。
Phyllis Smith. I mean, do we need to love her more? How can we love this woman more? She changed my life. She sure did. Sometimes, I think it just takes that one person who believes in you, you know? Yeah, we all need one person, right? We all need one advocate. I hope I'm that person to someone. You know, I think about all the people that helped me just keep going and still do. Yeah. I try to pay that forward as much as I can.
菲利斯·史密斯。我是说，我们还能更爱她一点吗？我们怎么能更爱这个女人呢？她改变了我的人生。她确实改变了。有时，我觉得只需要那么一个相信你的人，对吧？是的，我们都需要一个人，对吧？我们都需要一个支持者。我希望我对某个人来说就是那个人。你知道的，我想到了所有那些帮助我坚持下去并且现在还在帮助我的人。是的。我尽我所能把这份善意传递下去。
Yeah, me too. Fast fact number three, Angela. We also could not be making this podcast if we weren't best friends. That's true. I mean, Angela, I could not do this with anyone else truly. Oh my gosh, lady, come on. I mean, I love, oh my gosh, it's really hard for me to put into words how much I love our friendship. When I sit down.
是的，我也是。第三个快讯，安吉拉。如果我们不是最好的朋友，我们也绝对不可能制作这个播客。那是真的。我是说，安吉拉，除了你，我真的没法和任何人一起做这件事。哦，天哪，亲爱的，拜托。我是说，我爱，天哪，我很难用言语来表达我有多么热爱我们的友谊。当我坐下来。
God, you're going to make me cry. You just like zeroed in on my eyes with like such, like, love and appreciation. I feel moved. Well, I took my glasses off if that tells you guys listening anything. You know, when you take your glasses off, you're serious. That's what I mean. It got real serious. Well, I mean, you know, we just have this open dialogue. There's nothing I can't say to you. And it's very loving, you know, it's like, you always, always have made me want to be better. And like, I don't think there's a better compliment you can give anyone.
天哪，你这是要惹我哭啊。你刚才那种目光直视着我的眼睛，充满了爱与感激。我很感动。好吧，如果这能告诉收听节目的各位任何信息的话，我把眼镜摘了。你知道的，当你摘下眼镜时，你是认真的。这就是我的意思。事情变得严肃起来了。好吧，我是说，你知道，我们之间有着这种敞开的对话。没有什么是我不能对你说的。而且它是充满爱的，你知道的，就好像，你总是、总是让我想要变得更好。而且，我觉得你给不了任何人比这更好的赞美了。
Yeah. You know, you raise up my game. I don't know. I'm sure there's some lingo there the kids use. You level me up. I don't know what they say. That sounded good. Yeah. Thanks. I'll stick with it. But you do. Be the same. The gift of our friendship. It's everything to my life. I know. This whole process of doing this podcast and being co-boss ladies, it just tickles me to no end when we say that. But really, I was telling our kids that I feel like you're
是的。你知道的，你提升了我的水平。我不知道。我确信孩子们用了一些相关的俚语。你让我升级了。我不知道他们是怎么说的。听起来不错。是的。谢谢。我会一直用下去的。但你确实如此。也是一样。我们友谊的礼物。它对我的人生意义重大。我知道。制作这个播客并成为共同的女老板的整个过程，每当听到我们这么说，我都高兴得不得了。但真的，我曾对我们的孩子们说，我觉得你就是
my co-champion. Oh, yes. I love that. Yeah. Well, lady, we got this question from Shauna M. How did you two come to be best friends? When you point to a particular day or moment when something clicked or was it a gradual build? We actually get a lot of questions about our friendship, because I think it's- Well, we talk about our friendship a lot. I mean, how can you not? It's like the biggest
我的共同冠军。哦，是的。我太喜欢了。是的，亲爱的，我们收到了肖娜·M的问题。你们两个是怎么成为好朋友的？你能指出某个特定的日子或时刻，让你们觉得事情有了默契，还是慢慢培养出来的？我们其实收到了很多关于我们友谊的问题，因为我觉得——好吧，我们经常谈论我们的友谊。我是说，怎么能不谈呢？它就像是最大的
component to us. It's true. And I know we shared about spending those many days sitting next to one another on the bench in the basketball episode from season one. And that's kind of, that for me was like the beginning of our friendship. That was like, I stamp this person best friend. Yeah. No, we talked about it all. Like, I feel like we left the basketball episode and I was like, I know Jenna Fisher. Yes. That's how I felt too. Yes. So if I had to point to like one particular moment, that was it.
组成部分，对我们而言。确实如此。我知道我们分享过在第一季篮球那一集的板凳上紧挨着坐了好多天的经历。对我来说，那就是我们友谊的开始。就好像，我在这个人身上盖上了“最好朋友”的印章。是的。不，我们谈论过这一切。就像，我觉得我们拍完篮球那一集离开时，我就想：我认识珍娜·费舍尔。是的，我当时也是这种感觉。是的。所以如果要我指出某个特定的时刻，那就是那个时候。
But at the same time, the depth of our friendship was built over many years of showing up for one another. That's right. Okay. So Jenna, we've been talking a lot about the value of strong friendships in life. And I wanted to share this letter to you from our Office Ladies Mailbag. It really touched my heart. This is from Courtney J. My BFF and I had a falling out about six years ago. We are big fans of the office and we used to watch it together. Since listening to your podcast during quarantine, I was reminded of our friendship. Thanks to you ladies. And
但与此同时，我们友谊的深度是在多年来彼此支持的过程中建立起来的。没错。好的。所以，珍娜，我们一直在谈论生活中强大友谊的价值。我想与你分享这封来自我们《办公室》女士邮箱的信。它真的触动了我的心。这是柯特妮·J发来的。我和我最好的朋友在大约六年前闹翻了。我们是《办公室》的超级粉丝，我们曾经一起观看。自从在隔离期间收听你们的播客以来，我想起了我们的友谊。多亏了你们女士，以及
of how short and precious life is. My friend and I have since reconnected and we now bond over listening to office ladies each week. Thank you for inspiring me to get my best friend back. Oh my gosh. Courtney J, I am so happy that you got your friend back. Me too. I mean, how about that for a Monday motivation? Maybe reach out to someone you've lost touch with. I just love that. I know for a fact this past year, I feel like I have reconnected with people. I think just everything happening put so much into focus, you know? Yeah. You
生命是多么短暂和珍贵。我和我的朋友此后重新联系上了，我们现在每周通过收听《办公室》女士播客来维系感情。谢谢你们激励我找回了我最好的朋友。哦，天哪，柯特妮·J，我太高兴你能找回你的朋友了。我也是。我是说，这不就是最好的周一动力吗？也许可以联系一下那些你失去联系的人。我真的好喜欢这个。我知道事实上在过去的一年里，我觉得我重新和很多人取得了联系。我想仅仅是发生的这一切就把很多事情推到了焦点位置，你知道吗？是的。你
feel like the reasons you lose contact with people, like when you really look at them, it's like you can just put it all aside. Yeah. I love that idea. Courtney, I love that you reached out and I love that you guys are listening to us. I'm sending you an air hug. An air hug, sure. Yeah. Over the airwaves.
会觉得你和人们失去联系的原因，当你真正审视它们时，你会发现你可以把这一切都抛诸脑后。是的。我太喜欢这个想法了。柯特妮，我很高兴你主动联系了，我很高兴你们在收听我们的节目。我给你一个空气拥抱。空气拥抱，当然。是的。透过电波送达。
Yeah. And I think on that note, we'll take a little break. All right. Well, like we said earlier, this bonus episode is sponsored by Buick and Jenna, it's time to talk about the Buick Envision. We've been driving the Envision Avenir, which is new for 2021. It's their top of the line, most premium model, the highest expression of Buick luxury and this vehicle is amazing. I love it. I mean, I really love it. I love it too. I don't want to give it back.
是的，我觉得就此而言，我们要休息一下。好的。好吧，就像我们刚才说的，这个特别加长集是由别克赞助的，珍娜，是时候聊聊别克昂科威了。我们一直在开昂科威Avenir，这是2021年的新款。这是他们最高端、最具高级感的车型，是别克豪华的最高体现，这辆车太棒了。我喜欢它。我是说，我是真的喜欢它。我也很喜欢。我都不想还回去了。
I know. Me too. It works for me as a boss lady. It is totally luxurious, so I felt fancy. I felt pampered. I did too. It drives great, but it's also a total family vehicle. Like one of the available features is a hands-free power lift gate. So if your hands are full and you have the key in your pocket or your purse, you can just swipe your foot under the back bumper and the trunk opens automatically.
我知道。我也是。它作为女老板的车非常适合我。它极其豪华，让我感觉很华丽。我感觉被宠爱了。我也是。它开起来很棒，但它也完全是一辆家庭用车。比如其中一个可选功能是免提电动尾门。所以如果你的双手都占着，而钥匙在你的口袋或钱包里，你只需在后保险杠下方扫一下脚，后备箱就会自动打开。
Jenna and I tried this out in real time, you guys. Together. Together. We both did our feet under the bumper and they opened and we were so excited. Lady, we cheered and jumped up and down. In the parking lot. Yeah. It was very exciting. And by the way, our hands were full. That was really very convenient. Also, I just want to go sit in the Envision to do work. It's quieter than my house. It
珍娜和我现场试了这个，各位。一起试的。一起。我们俩同时把脚伸到保险杠下面，然后它就打开了，我们太兴奋了。亲爱的，我们欢呼并上下跳跃。在停车场。是的。非常令人兴奋。顺便说一句，我们的双手当时确实都拿满了东西。那真的非常方便。另外，我只想坐在昂科威里面办公。它比我的房子还要安静。它
smells better. Has multiple places to charge things and I'm in love with the seats. I know. Not only are they comfortable and they look so nice, but the driver's seat is heated. Yeah. Do you know what this means to me? Mm-hmm. It's always cold. This is important. And the driver's seat is like a massage chair. You heard me. It has a massage feature.
闻起来更好。有多个充电的地方，而且我爱死这些座位了。我知道。它们不仅舒适，看起来非常棒，而且驾驶座还是加热的。是的。你知道这对意味着什么吗？嗯。总是很冷。这很重要。而且驾驶座就像一把按摩椅。你没听错。它有按摩功能。
That's a standard feature on the Avenir. So while you're running, errands are just sitting in your driveway trying to do work. It's like you're getting a gentle rolling massage on your back. Listen, there are many things we loved about the Envision. It's zippy. It's got get up and go. It looks classy, but it's also super functional. And running my usual mom errands, it just felt like a mini vacation. The all new Buick Envision was an MVP for us these past few weeks. Staying motivated and staying on top of what we need is important in making the most of a busy week. And the
这是Avenir的标准配置。所以当你外出办事或者只是坐在车道上试图工作时。就好像你的后背正在接受温和的滚动按摩。听着，我们喜欢昂科威的原因有很多。它很有活力。它动力十足。它看起来很有档次，但同时也超级实用。在我日常处理妈妈杂务的时候，它感觉就像一个小小的假期。全新别克昂科威在过去几周里对我们来说就是MVP。保持动力并掌控我们需要做的事情，对于充分利用繁忙的一周至关重要。而
Envision really helped us out here. If you're looking for the right vehicle to help you do the same, check out the Buick Envision at Buick.com or at your local Buick dealer. And we are back. And now it's time to break down how we make office ladies. I thought we could kick things off with a question from Harris in Akron, Ohio. Hello, Harris. Hello, Harris. Okay. Harris says, I never knew how much I needed this podcast. It's been so great, especially this past year. What inspired you to make it? And thank you. I mean, Harris,
昂科威真的帮了我们大忙。如果你正在寻找合适的车来帮你做到这一点，请访问Buick.com或当地的别克经销商查看别克昂科威。我们回来了。现在是时候剖析我们是如何制作《办公室》女士播客的了。我想我们可以从俄亥俄州阿克伦市的哈里斯的一个问题开始。你好，哈里斯。你好，哈里斯。好的。哈里斯说，我以前从来不知道我有多么需要这个播客。它太棒了，尤其是过去的一年。是什么启发了你们制作它？谢谢你们。我是说，哈里斯，
come on. Thank you, Harris. I know. You're asking. What a lovely, lovely comment. Let's see. What inspired us to make it? I mean, I think the biggest thing that inspired us to make it was our desire to work together again. For sure.
拜托。谢谢你，哈里斯。我知道。你在问。多么可爱、多么可爱的评论啊。让我想想。是什么启发我们制作它的？我是说，我觉得启发我们制作它的最大原因是我们想要再次一起工作的渴望。绝对是的。
Yeah. Yeah. We've wanted to work together ever since the office ended. Like literally the day we drove off the Dunder Mifflin set, we were like, okay, when are we working together again? I know. Because we have to have lunch every day. And I wanted to do your show Haters Back Off, but I was super pregs and I couldn't travel. I know.
是的。自从《办公室》结束以来，我们就一直想一起工作。简直就是我们开车离开邓德米夫林片场的那一天，我们就说，好吧，我们什么时候能再一起工作？我知道。因为我们必须每天一起吃午饭。我想去你的剧《随性所欲》，但我当时超级大着肚子，无法旅行。我知道。
Remember that? Yes. And then you were like, and come be on my show. We did this back and forth. We're like, guys, hey, we just got a new job. Can my friend Jenna come by? Can she be in it? Is that obnoxious that we would get a job and we'd be like, do you have a role, maybe a scene I could do with my best friend? Is there a little quirky blonde lady can cruise through? Yeah. So we really just wanted to work together again. But I would say something else that
还记得吗？是的。然后你说，来我的剧里吧。我们这样推来推去。我们说，各位，嘿，我们刚刚得到了一份新工作。我的朋友珍娜能过来吗？她能在里面吗？如果我们得到一份工作然后说，你有没有一个角色，也许我可以和我最好的朋友一起拍一场戏，这会不会很讨厌？会不会有一个古怪的金发女士可以客串一下？是的。所以我们真的只是想再次一起工作。但我得说还有一件事
was happening after the office ended was we realized how spoiled we were on the office in the sense that the office hours were six a.m. to six p.m. I mean, we have Steve Krill to thank for that, right? We really do. He was such a family guy before any of us had families. Steve was the guy that had a family and he wanted to be home for dinner. He did. And so we were able to do this work schedule that was very family friendly and it was in one place. We rarely went on location or had night shoots. And when we did, it was
在《办公室》结束之后发生的事情是，我们意识到我们在《办公室》里被宠坏了，因为《办公室》的工作时间是早上六点到晚上六点。我是说，我们得感谢史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，对吧？我们真的必须感谢他。在我们的任何人有家庭之前，他就是一个顾家的男人。史蒂夫是个有家庭的人，他想回家吃晚饭。他确实是。所以我们能够制定这样一个非常适合家庭、并且在一个地方的工作时间表。我们很少去外景或进行夜间拍摄。而当我们这样做的时候，它
just fun because it was such a novelty. Right. And then as we started getting these jobs after the office, there was so much travel involved. We were away a lot. When we would talk about that, we would say, oh my gosh, in order to work as an actor, it seems like I have to go away or I have to work these jobs where Odd hours. Odd hours. And I was missing dinners and I was FaceTiming Bedtimes. And listen, I know
只是很有趣，因为这是一种新鲜感。没错。然后当我们开始在《办公室》之后接这些工作时，涉及了大量的旅行。我们经常不在家。每当我们谈到这一点时，我们就会说，天哪，为了作为一个演员工作，看起来我不得不离开家，或者我不得不做那些……不规律的工作。不规律的工作。而我错过了晚饭，我在FaceTime上陪睡。听着，我知道
this is true in a lot of professions. You've said before, your sister is a nurse and she'll have these three day shifts at the hospital that sort of take her out of commission. But as I was watching my kids growing up and thinking about, gosh, I wonder, is there a way we can be working together but more available to our families and home more? Yes. And this whole conversation was happening, by the way, while I was working on splitting up together, a TV show. And I would talk to Oliver Hudson about it. And he said one day, he said, well, Jenna, what you and Angela should do is a podcast. You'd be home all the time.
这在很多行业都是真的。你以前说过，你姐姐是一名护士，她在医院有三天的轮班，这让她基本上脱离了日常生活。但当我看着我的孩子们长大并思考时，天哪，我想知道，有没有一种方法我们可以一起工作，但对我们的家庭更有空、更多地待在家？是的。顺便说一句，这个对话是在我参与制作电视剧《分分合合》时发生的。我会和奥利弗·哈德森谈论这件事。有一天他说，他说，好吧，珍娜，你和安吉拉应该做的是播客。你就可以一直待在家了。
Oh my God, should I send Oliver Hudson a thank you? You probably should. I mean, he's who planted the seed. He 100% planted the seed. 100%. He was like, Jenna, I know how much you like to wear sweatpants. I know how much you love your BFF. I'm telling you, this job is going to tick all the boxes for you. You should really look into it. Now, meanwhile, you guys, I had been working on a show in Canada in Vancouver, which beautiful place, loved it. But I was flying back and forth and back and forth and back and forth.
天哪，我应该给奥利弗·哈德森寄一封感谢信吗？你大概真的应该。我是说，是他埋下了这颗种子。他百分之百埋下了这颗种子。百分之百。他当时说，珍娜，我知道你有多喜欢穿运动裤。我知道你有多爱你的好闺蜜。我告诉你，这份工作会满足你所有的要求。你真的应该考虑一下。现在，与此同时，各位，我当时一直在加拿大温哥华的一部剧里工作，虽然是个美丽的地方，我很喜欢。但我一直在飞来飞去，飞来飞去，飞来飞去。
So when Jenna was like, Ang, I have an idea here of how we could work in sweatpants and be home more. I was like, ding, ding, ding. Tell me about it. Yeah. So that was really the inspiration. Thank you, Oliver Hudson, for planting the seed. There will be a gift basket of some kind of muffins headed your way. Well, next, we have a question from Ben A, who asked, can you explain how a typical podcast episode gets recorded? What does a typical week look like for you? This is actually such a good question. My kids have asked this because they get to see part
所以当珍娜说：“安吉，我有个主意，我们可以穿着运动裤工作，还能多呆在家里。”我当时就想：太棒了，说来听听。对。所以这真的是灵感来源。谢谢你，奥利弗·哈德逊，种下了这颗种子。一会儿会有一个装着某种松饼的礼篮送到你那儿去。好，接下来，我们有一个来自本·A（Ben A）的问题，他问：“你们能解释一下一集典型的播客是怎么录制的吗？对你们来说，典型的一周是什么样的？”这其实是一个非常好的问题。我的孩子们也问过这个问题，因为他们能看到一部分
of the process, right? Yeah. And they really want to come in the studio. My kids do, too. I know. We need to have, oh my God. Family day. Family day. Sam and Cassie, we're going to have family day. So because they just see the part of it at home. Yeah. All right. So let's break it down. Okay. So Angela, how do you start your week when you plan for the podcast? Well, first of all, I watch the episode we're breaking down like three or four times. Same.
流程对吧？对。而且他们真的很想进录音室。我的孩子们也是。我知道。我们需要来个，天哪。家庭日。家庭日。萨姆和卡西，我们要搞个家庭日。因为他们只能看到在家里的那部分。对。好吧。那我们来拆解一下。好吧。安吉拉，当你为播客做规划时，你的一周是怎么开始的？嗯，首先，我要把我正在剖析的那集剧集看上三四遍。我也是。
Right? Yes. So I first I watch it just like, just like as an audience member. And the kids usually watch it with me because my kids, you know, are older and they're really into it. So I watch it with them. It's so interesting to see the things they love, you know? And then I'll watch it again. And I have my outline. We have an outline, you guys, of the episode, like a scene by scene outline that we print out. Yes. Our associate producer, Ainsley Bubaco, puts that together for us. Thank you, Ainsley.
对吧？是的。所以我先看第一遍，就像，就像普通观众那样看。孩子们通常会跟我一起看，因为我的孩子们，你知道，都比较大了，而且他们真的很喜欢这个节目。所以我陪他们一起看。看他们喜欢的东西真的很有趣，你知道吗？然后我会再看一遍。我有一份大纲，大家听好了，我们有一份剧集的大纲，就像那种我们打印出来的逐场大纲。是的。我们的助理制片人安斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubaco）为我们整理了这份大纲。谢谢你，安斯利。
So my second pass at watching it, I watch it with that outline. And I go through and I just start making notes. You guys, my notes used to be on note cards that Angela has graduated everybody to adult good. Listen, she uses a proper outline. Applause for you, lady. I know. I put it all in one word document now, but I did that because I was in the closet, my husband's closet podcasting for a year and I had no room for my note cards. I know. I still feel like I miss the note card. If I'm honest with you. Well, back in studio, they're coming back. So get ready. All right.
所以我的第二遍观看，我是对照着那份大纲看的。我过一遍，然后开始做笔记。各位，我的笔记以前都是写在便签卡上的，而安吉拉已经让每个人都升级到成年人的水平了。听着，她用的是正规的大纲。为你鼓掌，女士。我知道。我现在把它们全部放在一个Word文档里了，我这么做是因为我以前在衣帽间里，在我丈夫的衣帽间里做了一年播客，我的便签卡根本没地方放。我知道。老实说，我还是觉得挺怀念便签卡的。说实话。好吧，回到录音室，它们又要回来了。所以做好准备吧。好吧。
But anyway, so then I start making notes. Then we start really doing research. Anything that's mentioned in the episode that I'm curious about, I'll start, you know, googling it and looking it up and finding out information. We'll reach out to cast and crew with questions. Then I personally take the DVD commentary, deleted scenes and bloopers, right, Jenna? Yep. And you really go into fan questions. Yes. And that's also with help from Ainsley. She'll pull questions from our mailbag, from our Instagram, and she sends them to me. And then I go through and try to figure out what
但不管怎样，然后我开始做笔记。接着我们开始真正做调研。剧集里提到的任何我好奇的事情，我都会开始，你知道的，去谷歌搜索，查阅资料，寻找信息。我们会带着问题联系演员和剧组。然后我个人会负责DVD随片评论、删减片段和花絮，对吧，珍娜？没错。而且你真的深入研究了粉丝的问题。是的。这也是在安斯利的帮助下完成的。她会从我们的邮箱、我们的Instagram上收集问题，然后发给我。接着我会过一遍，试着弄清楚
do we know the answer to. Yeah. And we will trade off texting, casting, crew. So Jenna will reach out to people. I reach out to people. I mean, we just couldn't do the podcast without the love and support of the office family. It's true. And you know, in this whole process, because mine is very similar to yours, Angela, the way I watch it, we try not to tell each other specifically what we're doing because I want to surprise Angela. Like I, I don't always tell her my fast facts. I don't always tell her my deep dives.
哪些问题我们知道答案。对。我们会轮流给演员和剧组发短信。所以珍娜会联系一些人，我也会联系一些人。我是说，如果没有办公室大家庭的爱与支持，我们根本做不出这个播客。确实如此。你知道的，在整个过程中——因为我的方式和你的非常相似，安吉拉，我观看的方式——我们尽量不具体告诉对方我们在做什么，因为我想给安吉拉一个惊喜。比如我，我并不总是把我的“快速冷知识”告诉她。我并不总是把我的“深度剖析”告诉她。
Same, same. Like if there is a nugget in the DVD commentary are my favorite, a deleted scene that I know is going to rock your world. I won't tell you. I will give the audio clips to Sam and let him play it and you react in the moment. So after all of this prep, we record our episodes every Thursday. And then we edit the following week. So our producer, Cassie Jerkins and our sound engineer, Sam Kiefer, they will put together the episode. They assemble it for us. And then we get to listen to it and then we give notes. This is going to be weird to say, you guys, I love, I love listening to the podcast. I
一样，一样。比如如果在DVD随片评论里有什么我最喜欢的宝贝内容，或者我知道会惊艳到你的删减片段，我是不会告诉你的。我会把音频剪辑发给萨姆，让他播放，然后你当场做出反应。所以在完成所有这些准备工作之后，我们每周四录制节目。然后在接下来的一周进行剪辑。所以我们的制片人卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）和我们的音响工程师萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），他们会把节目拼凑到一起。他们为我们组装好节目。然后我们就可以听了，并给出意见。说出来可能会有点奇怪，各位，我喜欢，我喜欢听这个播客。我
love it. We do. We do you guys. I will, this is like such a lame story, but I listen to it while I do chores. You do too, Jenna. Oh yeah. My favorite things is to listen to it while I fold clothes. And Josh walked in, my husband and I was just smiling. I was just grinning ear to ear and he was like, what you listening to? And I was like, oh, me and Jenna, oh my gosh, you're such a dork.
太喜欢了。我们真的很喜欢，各位。我，这听起来可能是一个很无聊的故事，但我做家务时会听它。你也是，珍娜。哦，对。我最喜欢的事情之一就是一边叠衣服一边听。然后乔什——我丈夫——走了进来，而我正咧着嘴笑。我当时笑得合不拢嘴，他问：“你在听什么呢？”我说：“哦，我和珍娜，哦天哪，你真是个书呆子。”
Well, it's like I get to hang out with you for a whole hour. Yeah. And so after we have listened to ourselves and been delighted by ourselves and tackle big chores, cause Jenna, you have told me you'll, you'll like save a big chore in the house. Like you're like going to organize your pantry. Oh, I organized my son's closet while I listened to dinner party because I was like, that's a long one. That's a good closet cleaning chore. I can get a big, I can get a big project done. Exactly. So then we have a zoom with Sam and Cassie where we go through our notes together
好吧，就好像我能跟你一起闲逛整整一个小时。对。所以，在我们听了自己的节目、被自己逗乐并搞定了繁重的家务之后——因为珍娜，你曾跟我说过，你会，你会把家里的一项重体力活留着。比如你准备整理一下你的食品储藏室。哦，我听《晚宴》（Dinner Party）那一集时顺便把我儿子的衣帽间整理了，因为我想，那一集挺长的。那是个适合大扫除的累活。我能完成一个大工程。完全正确。然后我们会和萨姆、卡西开个Zoom会议，我们一起过一遍笔记
and we discuss things we want to cut out, things we want to keep. And guys, I know I've seen comments that are like, why do you edit anything? I want to listen to it. You don't, you don't. Oh my gosh. First of all, sometimes like we're recording and I'm like, I'm really hungry. So I start eating a granola bar. You don't need to hear that. You don't need to hear that. We need to edit out meat crunching. I mean, we've been known to go on some tangents.
讨论我们想删掉什么，想保留什么。伙计们，我知道我见过一些评论说：“你们干嘛要剪辑？我想听原汁原味的。”你们不想，你们真的不想。天哪。首先，有时我们在录音时我会觉得：我真的很饿。于是我开始吃燕麦能量棒。你们不需要听到那个。你们不需要听到那个。我们需要把咀嚼声剪掉。我的意思是，我们有时会扯得很远。
Oh, real long tangents. Can you believe it guys? Are you shocked? And then, and then also sometimes they'll be part of the episode that we both separately loved and we both bring similar information. So then we decide, okay, wait, Jenna, I kind of like your, your spin on that. Or I like what you researched. You lead with that. I'll take this. Sometimes we're, we're sorting it out right then and there. Yeah. Well, that's kind of how we do it. I would say overall we spend about 20 to 25 hours per week working on the podcast. It's a full time part time job. And that's kind
哦，扯得超级远。你们敢相信吗，伙计们？你们震惊吗？然后，然后有时节目的一部分是我们俩都各自喜欢的，而且我们俩收集了相似的信息。所以我们会决定：“好吧，等等，珍娜，我挺喜欢你对那个话题的切入角度的。或者我喜欢你研究的内容。你用那个开头吧，我接这个。”有时我们当场就把这些理清了。对。好吧，我们大致就是这样做的。我想总的来说，我们每周花大约20到25个小时来做这个播客。这是一份全职的兼职工作。差不多就是
of the, that's the long and long of it, I think, right? Ben, did we go on too long? So sorry, Ben. Sorry, Ben. And I guess I do want to say one more thing. I want to give a shout out to our executive producer, Cody Fisher, because we just couldn't do this without our team and our partnership with Ear Wolf. We're very grateful. We are so grateful. And then I just want to say that one of the things that has gotten
情况就是这样，对吧？本，我们是不是聊得太久了？太对不起了，本。对不起，本。我想我还要再说一件事。我要感谢我们的执行制片人科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher），因为如果没有我们的团队以及与Earwolf的合作，我们根本无法做到这一点。我们非常感激。我们太感激了。然后我只想说，过去这一年里，支撑我
me through this past year has been our team at Ear Wolf and has been our weekly edit sessions. Not only do I enjoy doing the podcast with Jenna, but I equally enjoy hanging out with Sam and Cassie over a Zoom. We always have some hot topic we have to chitty-chat about at the top before we get to work. And just seeing their faces, even though it's been on a TV, has just, I don't know, I just look forward to it. Well, this leads me very well into our next question, Angela, from Natasha B. What would you say is the most challenging aspect of making the podcast each week? Does working with your best friend make things easier or harder? Like, do you waste time in meetings
度过难关的正是我们在Earwolf的团队，以及我们每周的剪辑会议。不仅我很享受和珍娜一起做播客，我也同样享受在Zoom上和萨姆、卡西闲逛。在开始工作前，我们总有几个热门话题要在开场时闲聊一番。看到他们的脸，尽管是通过电脑屏幕，我还是，怎么说呢，我就是很期待。好吧，这非常自然地引出了我们的下一个问题，安吉拉，来自娜塔莎·B（Natasha B）。你觉得每周制作播客最具挑战性的一面是什么？和你的好闺蜜一起工作会让事情变得更容易还是更难？比如，你们在会议上会不会因为
just chatting as friends? Well, okay, okay, Natasha, I definitely think being best friends makes it easier in so many ways, right? Yeah, I do. We're both really efficient and I don't think we waste each other's time, although we, yeah, we do a lot of gabbing on the Zoom before. It's more of a question for Cassie and Sam, maybe. Yeah, do we gab too much?
光顾着作为朋友聊天而浪费时间？好吧，好吧，娜塔莎，我绝对认为作为好朋友在很多方面让事情变得更容易了，对吧？是的，我也是。我们两个的工作效率都很高，而且我不认为我们是在浪费彼此的时间，虽然我们在，对，我们在Zoom开会前确实会闲聊很多。这也许更应该去问卡西和萨姆。对，我们是不是闲聊太多了？
We don't gab too much, Sam. I think it's an accurate amount. I think it's just the right amount. An accurate amount. That's an interesting choice of word. Well, Sam. I think it's a healthy amount. Healthy amount. You also have really good stories, too. Yeah, I think I'm okay with it because I contribute so much to it.
我们没有闲聊太多，萨姆。我觉得这是一个恰当的量。我觉得正好合适。一个恰当的量。这是一个很有意思的词。好吧，萨姆。我觉得这是一个健康的量。健康的量。而且你们的故事确实也很有趣。对，我觉得我能接受，因为我对节目的贡献很大。
Maybe this is a question for Cassie. Yeah, exactly. Cassie. Just talk on a Zoom. I know. All right. I agree that we both have a good work ethic. We're both very driven people. What would you say is the most challenging? About doing the podcast?
也许这个问题应该去问卡西。对，没错。卡西。只管在Zoom上说话就行。我知道。好吧。我同意我们俩都有很好的职业道德。我们都是很有进取心的人。你觉得最具挑战性的是什么？关于做播客？
Yeah. The most challenging. I think for me, it's just that I want to make sure we get it right. The office is this hugely popular, beloved show to so many people. The truth is the fans, they know the show. You guys know the show better than anyone. Every week, I just want Jenna and I to do right by you guys. I also want to do right by the cast and crew. Hundreds of people work together every week to make the office come to life. Each and every one of them were an integral part of the show's success. Jenna and I talk about this all the time. We just want everyone represented. We want
对。最具挑战性的。对劳说，我觉得就是我想确保我们能把它做好。《办公室》是一部对这么多人来说超级受欢迎、备受喜爱的剧集。事实是，粉丝们很了解这部剧。你们比任何人都更了解这部剧。每周，我都希望我和珍娜能不辜负你们的期望。我也希望不辜负演员和剧组的期望。数百人每周齐心协力，才让《办公室》栩栩如生。他们每个人都是这部剧成功的不可或缺的一部分。我和珍娜一直在谈论这个。我们只是希望每个人都被代表。我们希望
to be able to share all the stories, all the little tidbits. I think the pressure I feel is I don't want to let the show's legacy down. Yeah. We do miss things. We do. Yeah. We get things wrong. We get it wrong. I really love our office ladies, listeners, this community of people.
能够分享所有的故事、所有的精彩小花絮。我觉得我感受到的压力在于，我不想让这部剧的传奇色彩失望。对。我们确实会漏掉一些东西。确实。是的。我们也会弄错。我们确实会弄错。我真的很爱我们的《办公室女士》听众们，这群社区里的人。
You guys are so kind and you will lovingly let us know when we got it wrong. That's the whole reason we started doing the Revisited episodes. For me, the most challenging aspect of making the podcast is probably just what's most challenging for me in general in my life, I'm going to share, is just managing my anxiety and nervousness. It was especially hard for me as an actress because sets are a very social environment. I think sometimes people assume that all actors are just extroverts and that we have this natural ease with being in the spotlight, but that is definitely not the case for me.
你们太善良了，当我们弄错的时候，你们会充满爱意地提醒我们。这就是我们开始做重温剧集（Revisited）节目的全部原因。对我来说，制作播客最具挑战性的方面，可能也就是我生活中最让我感到挑战的方面，我要分享出来，那就是如何管理我的焦虑和紧张情绪。作为一名演员，这对我来说尤其艰难，因为片场是一个非常社交的环境。我想有时人们会认为所有演员都只是外向的人，我们在聚光灯下有一种天生的松弛感，但对我来说绝对不是这样的。
In a lot of ways, the podcast is a much better fit for me because our team is small. I do better in small groups of people, but even still it is a challenge. Well, you've shared a lot with me about this over the years and you have a really great analogy that I thought was so helpful. You call it your backpack analogy and I want you to share it because Jenna, I think it's relatable and I've shared it with my kids because we all have stress and anxiety. It's something we all deal with. It manifests differently for everyone, but this is a great way to explain your stress. Will you tell us about it?
在很多方面，播客其实更适合我，因为我们的团队很小。我在小群体的人际交往中表现得更好，但即便如此，这依然是一个挑战。好吧，这些年你跟我分享了很多关于这方面的事情，你有一个非常棒的比喻，我觉得超级有用。你把它叫做你的“背包比喻”，我想让你分享一下，因为珍娜，我觉得这个比喻很有共鸣，我也把它分享给我的孩子们，因为我们都有压力和焦虑。这是我们所有人都要面对的事情。它在每个人身上的表现形式不同，但这确实是解释你压力的一种绝佳方式。你能给我们讲讲吗？
Yes, my backpack analogy. The way I think about it is my anxiety is a backpack that I wear every single day. I take it with me every time, but some days the backpack is heavy and some days it's light and some days it really weighs me down and makes it super hard to walk through my day and sometimes I barely notice it, but it's always there and I'm never going to get rid of it. What I love about our friendship and getting to work with someone who knows me so intimately is you have said to me, lady, how heavy is the backpack today? Then I can tell you. Then I have different strategies for managing a heavy backpack, but sometimes, man, the heavy backpack, you wake up, there's no reason for
好的，我的背包比喻。我是这样想的：我的焦虑就像是一个我每天都背着的背包。我每次出门都会带着它，但有时背包很沉，有时背包很轻，有时它真的很让我透不过气，让我的日常生活变得步履维艰，而有时我几乎注意不到它，但它一直都在，而且我永远也甩不掉它。我最喜欢我们的友谊以及能和这样一个如此了解我的人共事的一点是，你曾对我说过：“女士，今天的背包有多重？”然后我就可以告诉你了。接着我就会有不同的策略来应对沉重的背包，但有时候，天哪，背着沉重的背包，你一醒来，根本没有理由。
it. You're just like, man, it's a heavy backpack day. You've got to be kidding me. Come on. I hate that, but you know, that's what it is. I'm no longer looking to get rid of the backpack and I don't expect to and just that little shift of acknowledging that it's always there has really helped me a lot. Yeah. It's just me and it comes with me. Right. And that you're going to be okay. Yes.
你就会想：“天哪，今天是个重背包日。”你是在跟我开玩笑吧。拜托。我讨厌这样，但你知道，事实就是如此。我不再指望摆脱这个背包了，我也不抱这种期望，仅仅是做出了这种微小的转变，承认它一直都在，真的帮了我很大忙。是的。它就是我的一部分，它和我形影不离。对。而且你会没事的。是的。
Well, I love you and your backpack. Well, thanks, lady. Thanks. You helped me carry my backpack a lot. Yeah. Well, since we're talking about our friendship and all the ways it relates back to the podcast, Jenna, I have a fan question. Okay. From Molly S. How has your friendship changed while making this podcast? Have you found out new things about each other?
好吧，我爱妳，也爱妳的背包。谢谢你，女士。谢谢。你帮我分担了很多背包的重量。是的。既然我们在谈论我们的友谊以及它与播客的所有联系，珍娜，我有一个来自粉丝的问题。好的。来自莫莉·S（Molly S）。在制作这个播客的过程中，你们的友谊发生了怎样的变化？你们有没有发现彼此身上的一些新特点？
Well, yeah. Well, first of all, I had no idea Angela loved no cards so much. I really didn't. Angela also wears lipstick to every zoom. Like she will not do her hair. She might be in a bath robe, but she put on lipstick. I find that hilarious. Well, here's the thing. Jenna always has great hair. Like I don't get it. Like almost every morning for our zooms, she blows out her hair like this beautiful blowout. Today I am looking at her and she has a beautiful blowout, but she never wears lipstick. No, never. I can't tell you how many interviews, press junkets, red carpets we have done. We're
嗯，对。首先，我完全不知道安吉拉这么喜欢便签卡。我真的不知道。安吉拉每次开Zoom会议都会涂口红。哪怕她不打理头发。她可能穿着浴袍，但她一定会涂口红。我觉得这太搞笑了。好吧，事情是这样的。珍娜总是有一头好头发。我就是搞不懂。几乎我们每次开Zoom的早晨，她都会把头发吹得像这样漂亮的吹风造型。今天我看着她，她顶着一个漂亮的吹风造型，但她从来不涂口红。对，从来不。我无法告诉你我们做过多少次采访、新闻发布会、红毯。我们
about to step out to have our photo taken and I'll be like, lady, you have no lipstick on. Yeah, I hate lipstick. And I don't feel like presentable unless I have lipstick on, which makes me feel like between the two of us, we're almost a fully dressed person. This is true, right? I need my hair done and then I feel done. Oh no, I throw it in a ponytail, but I put on my lips.
正准备走出去拍照，然后我就会说：“女士，你没涂口红。”对，我讨厌口红。而且除非涂了口红，否则我感觉自己没法见人，这让我觉得在我们俩之间，我们加起来才算是一个完整打扮好的人。确实如此，对吧？我需要把头发弄好，然后我才觉得自己准备好了。哦不，我随便扎个马尾辫，但我一定要涂口红。
Well, lady, I have a quiz for us. Okay. The best friends quiz that I found online, it was on Hello Giggles and it has like 40 questions. I'm not going to ask you 40 questions. Oh my gosh. I just pulled a few that were fun, but I thought this would be fun to try and see, maybe we'll see how well we know each other and maybe we'll even learn something new now. Are you ready?
好吧，女士，我给我们准备了一个小测验。好的。我在网上找到的“闺蜜小测验”，它在Hello Giggles网站上看到的，大概有40个问题。我不会问你40个问题的。天哪。我只是挑了几个有趣的，但我觉得试一下会很有趣，也许我们可以看看彼此到底有多了解对方，说不定还能学到新东西呢。准备好了吗？
Is this the end of our friendship? I'm kidding. I hope not. I'm kidding. If it is, you're hearing it now. I'm kidding. Okay. Yes, I'm ready. Okay.
这是我们友谊的尽头吗？开玩笑的。我希望不是。开玩笑的。如果是的话，那你现在就听到了。开玩笑的。好的，我准备好了。好的。
No, it's fun. Number one. Okay. So what I do best on, or you can answer this question, if I were stuck on a desert island, why would I be an asset? Okay. Lady, you would be great on reality TV, but you'd also get kicked off too quickly. So you're basically saying I would make great TV.
不，这挺有趣的。第一题。好的。所以我最擅长什么，或者你可以回答这个问题：如果我被困在荒岛上，我为什么会是一个优势？好的，女士，你在真人秀节目里会表现得很棒，但你也会被淘汰得太快了。所以你基本上是说我会成为很好的电视素材。
Oh yeah. Because I'd be a hot mess. We'd all want to watch you, but I feel like you would tell someone off or something. You would want to change the rules. You'd get kicked off. They'd vote you off or you'd get kicked off. And we'd be sad to see you go because you would have been the best thing about it. And so I'm going to pivot to the desert island question.
哦，对。因为你会把事情搞得一团糟。我们都会想看你，但我觉得你会把某个人骂一顿或者干出点什么。你会想改变规则。你会遭到淘汰。他们会投票把你投出去，或者你会被驱逐。我们会难过地看你离开，因为你将是其中最棒的亮点。所以我要把话题转回荒岛问题上。
Okay. Okay. I think you'd be an asset because you're very smart and you're a survivalist. You really are. And you remember the most random trivia, like you would be the person who would be like, oh, wait, wait, I know this. I know how to collect rain, water, and a jungle. I know how to do this.
好的。好的。我觉得你会是一个优势，因为你很聪明，而且你是个生存主义者。你真的是。而且你会记住最随机的冷知识，比如你就是那种会说：“哦，等等，等等，我知道这个。我知道怎么在丛林里收集雨水。我知道怎么做这个。”的人。
Thank you for saying that because, you know, my family is a really big fan of the show Survivor. I know. And I always see them get their chickens, you know. And I remember this one time they were having this big debate about whether or not they should save the eggs or if they should hard boil them and save them. And I just wanted to scream at the TV, no, fresh laid eggs can go days unrefrigerated. But the minute you boil it, you have to eat it, y'all, or you have to refrigerate it.
谢谢你这么说，因为，你知道的，我的家人是《幸存者》（Survivor）节目的超级粉丝。我知道。我总是看到他们去抓鸡，你知道的。我记得有一次，他们为了是该把鸡蛋留着还是应该把它们煮熟保存而争论不休。我当时真想对着电视大喊：“不，刚生下来的鸡蛋不放冰箱可以存放好几天！但你一旦把它煮熟了，大家听着，你就必须立刻吃掉它，或者把它放进冰箱。”
Do not boil those eggs. Do not boil them. This is why I think you'd be good on the island. Thank you. But not good on Survivor because, like, the first week you'd be like, I'm sorry, but that is highly inappropriate. I would have a very hard time. I think this challenge is demeaning.
千万别把那些鸡蛋煮了。绝对不要煮。这就是为什么我觉得你在岛上会表现得不错。谢谢。但在《幸存者》里表现不会好，因为，比如第一周你就会说：“对不起，这非常不合适。”我会觉得很难熬。我觉得这个挑战太有辱人格了。
Well, it's funny you say this because my family has actually been rewatching Survivor together. My kids are super into it. And my answer was going to be that I think you would be amazing on Survivor. I think you could win it all. Why? Because you are a hard worker and you don't complain. That's why, now, listen, we both have hard worker in common, but that second one on the
好吧，你这么说很有意思，因为我的家人最近其实一直在一起重温《幸存者》。我的孩子们超级迷这个。而我的回答本来是，我觉得你在《幸存者》里会表现得惊艳。我觉得你能赢得最后的胜利。为什么？因为你是一个工作努力且从不抱怨的人。这就是为什么——听着，我们都有努力工作这个共同点，但清单上的第二点
list would get you booted. Exactly. But you would be very friendly. You would get to know people on, like, this really personal level. You would be social, but you also would not be perceived as a physical threat. Even though I think you would do really well in a lot of the challenges, I think you could fly under the radar. You would be likable.
会让你被踢出局。完全正确。但你会非常友好。你会以这种非常私人的方式去了解人们。你会很善于社交，但同时你也不会被视作是一种身体上的威胁。尽管我觉得你在很多挑战中都会表现得很好，但我觉得你可以低调行事。你会很讨人喜欢。
I think you could win it all. Thank you, Jenna. All right. Thank you. I never want to do it because they don't show where they go to the bathroom and I don't want to poop in the woods. So. Yeah, they go to the bathroom and a hole in the ground, I think.
我觉得你能赢得最后的胜利。谢谢你，珍娜。好的。谢谢。我永远不想去参加那个节目，因为他们不播他们去哪里上厕所，而我可不想在树林里大便。所以。对，我想他们是在地上的一个洞里上厕所。
Yeah, I'm out. Are you ready for the next question? Yes. If I became president, what do you think I'd do first? Jenna, you would do so many things. You would be such a great president. Hey, thanks. You really would.
好吧，我退出。准备好迎接下一个问题了吗？准备好了。如果我当了总统，你觉得我第一件会做的事是什么？珍娜，你会做很多事情。你会成为一个如此优秀的总统。嘿，谢谢。你真的会的。
First of all, you're very fair. And so I feel like you would really be there for everybody. And I know for sure you would make sure men and women get paid maternity leave as part of their job. I would. And of course, come on, equal pay for equal pockets. That would be my first executive order. Yeah.
首先，你非常公正。所以我感觉你会真正为每个人着想。而且我敢肯定，你会确保无论男女都能把带薪产假作为他们工作的一部分。我会的。当然了，拜托，同工同酬。这将是我的第一道行政命令。对。
All right. Well, I think you would learn every single name of every single person who works in the White House. I would. And you would know a specific detail about all of their families. I would. And they'd all get cake on their birthday. They would.
好吧，我觉得你会记住白宫里每一个工作人员的名字。我会的。而且你会知道他们所有人家庭的具体细节。我会的。并且他们在生日时都能吃到蛋糕。他们会的。
It would be a lot of birthday cakes in the White House. You would be literally the most personable president ever. And as far as policies, that was a tough one for me because you do not soap box very often. But I know that education is very important to you. Your sister is a teacher. So I could see you advocating for teachers in a really big way. I really would. Yeah.
白宫里会有很多的生日蛋糕。你绝对是有史以来最平易近人的总统。至于政策方面，对我来说这挺难回答的，因为你很少发表长篇大论。但我知道教育对你非常重要。你姐姐是一名老师。所以我能看出你会以一种非常宏大的方式为老师们发声。我真的会。是的。
For education, for our teachers and our children. All right, final question, Angela. When we are 85 years old, what will we be doing together? Oh, my goodness. Well, I hope we are sitting on a porch together, gabbing away about anything and everything. That's what I hope. I wrote two words. What?
为了教育，为了我们的老师和孩子们。好的，最后一个问题，安吉拉。当我们85岁的时候，我们会一起做些什么？哦，天哪。好吧，我希望我们能一起坐在门廊上，天南海北地闲聊。这就是我希望的。我写了两个词。什么？
Factory tours. Oh, my gosh, I love it. But no stairs. 85. We need an elevator. Or a ramp. Or a ramp. Yeah.
工厂参观。哦，天哪，我太喜欢了。但不能有楼梯。85岁了。我们需要一部电梯。或者一个斜坡。或者一个斜坡。对。
Well, if you guys want to do this quiz with your friends, we'll put a swipe up to it in our stories. We'll put it on OfficeLadies.com. You can do all 40 questions if you want. We're nearing the end here, guys. A final question from Arden in Minnesota. Have you learned anything new about the office by doing this rewatch podcast? I feel like we've learned so much.
好吧，如果你们想和朋友们一起做这个测验，我们会在故事里放一个上滑链接。我们把它放到OfficeLadies.com上。如果你想的话，你可以做完所有40个问题。各位，我们快到尾声了。来自明尼苏达州的阿尔登（Arden）的最后一个问题：通过做这个重温播客，你们对《办公室》有什么新的了解吗？我觉得我们学到了太多。
I mean, every week we learn so much about each episode. For example, I, of course, didn't think I would become so obsessed with the plants at front reception. I mean, either. I love it, though. But now it's like the first thing I look for. And then we both have characters we have fallen back in love with. I mean, I live for every single word that Phyllis says.
我是说，每周我们都会从每一集学到很多。比如，我当然没想到自己会变得对前台的植物如此痴迷。我是说，我也没想到。不过我真的很喜欢。但现在这成了我注意的第一个东西。然后我们俩都有了重新爱上的角色。我是说，菲利斯（Phyllis）说的每一个字我都爱听。
Yes. Well, I have a whole new appreciation for Ryan the Temp. Yeah. I also love how you've noticed little things like the way John says D-white. It's two words. D-white. D-white. Or, you know, go into the full Mindy.
是的。好吧，我对临时工瑞安（Ryan the Temp）有了全新的欣赏。是的。我也很喜欢你注意到的那些小细节，比如约翰（John）说“德怀特”（D-white）的方式。那是两个词。德怀特。德怀特。或者，你知道的，开启完全的明迪（Mindy）模式。
That was so fun. Yes. And then just how we've developed an even deeper appreciation for our crew. I mean, we appreciated them. But as we go through these episodes and, for example, learn what went into putting those plants on Pam's desk. Right. Or how that bobblehead, how Dwight's bobblehead came to be.
太好玩了。是的。还有我们对剧组的感激之情变得更加深厚了。我是说，我们本来就很感激他们。但当我们看这些剧集时，例如，知道了把那些植物放在帕姆（Pam）桌上到底经历了什么。对。或者那个摇头娃娃，德怀特的摇头娃娃是怎么来的。
Yeah. Our crew is amazing. Well, there you have it. Yes. Our bonus episode of Office Ladies, sponsored by the awesome folks at Buick, is complete. Well, Jenna, I really love doing this episode. Me, too. I think it was so fun.
是的，我们的剧组太棒了。好了，就是这样。是的。由别克（Buick）汽车的出色伙伴们赞助的《办公室女士》彩蛋集到此结束。好吧，珍娜，我真的很喜欢这一集。我也是。我觉得太有趣了。
Yeah. I think next time we should do a bonus episode called Friday Feeling. Yes. Let's break down Friday Feeling and how you get there. I like it. Well, thank you for sending in your questions. We will put a swipe up in our stories to the best friend quiz and a swipe up to the all-new Envision.
对。我觉得下次我们应该做一个名为“周五感觉”（Friday Feeling）的彩蛋集。太好了。让我们来剖析一下周五感觉以及你是如何进入这种状态的。我喜欢。好吧，谢谢你们发来问题。我们会在故事里放一个通往闺蜜测验的上滑链接，以及一个通往全新Envision的上滑链接。
If you want to check it out, or you can go to Buick.com. I'm sad we have to give the Envisions back. I'm really going to miss my heated Inventive Massage Driver seat. It's just like my rolling spa. I know. Well, guys, thank you so much for listening, and we hope this episode helps you stay motivated to crush the week ahead. Bye, you guys.
如果你想了解一下，也可以访问Buick.com。我很遗憾我们要把Envision还回去。我会非常怀念我的带有加热功能的创变按摩驾驶座椅。它就像我的移动水疗馆一样。我知道。好吧，伙计们，非常感谢你们的收听，我们希望这一集能帮助你们保持动力，去征服接下来的一周。再见，伙计们。
Bye, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是安斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. Thank you for listening and I bestow my strands of advice on you. Bye, yes. Bye. Bye guys. Bye! You guys enjoyed the episode with Ainsley, right? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。谢谢大家的收听，我将我的一串串建议赠予你们。再见，好的。再见。再见，伙计们。拜拜！你们很喜欢和安斯利一起录制的这一集，对吧？本集目前还没有评论。点击节目文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。